When President Trump meets South Korea's
new president Moon Jae-In at their first
Washington summit in June 2017, the two
leaders will have a chance to forge a
personal bond that could strengthen the
US-ROK alliance against growing North
Korean threats. But the meeting also
entails non-trivial risks. President Moon
favors a departure from the current
joint US-ROK approach towards North
Korea and return instead to a sunshine
policy, the more conciliatory engagement
oriented posture with which Seoul
experimented during the Clinton and
George W. Bush administrations. President
Moon wishes to reverse, or at least
suspend, South Korea's implementation of
THAAD missile defense. He wishes to reopen
the ROK sponsored Kaesong Industrial
Complex in the north, shut down by his
predecessor on suspicion it was funneling
money to Kim Jong-Un's nuclear and
missile program. Also, he seems
uncomfortable pressing North Korea on
its human rights violations. Last time
around sunshine policies caused US-ROK
relations to suffer and North Korea
profited. Will moonshine fare better?
Stay tuned.
To learn more about my take on
North Korea, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you want a AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.